[Music]
um as uh I think it was President Reagan
said we're from the government we're
here to help surely you can't be serious
I think you all know that I've always
felt the nine most terrifying words in
the English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to
help
hello people I'm Dave Rubin this is the
rubben report it's November 28th
2023 that was education secretary Miguel
Cardona who should be fired from his job
immediately and that would not be cancel
culture that would be justified culture
he is the head of the Department of
Education and he completely 180 reverse
butchered that quote from Ronald Reagan
a quote that I actually often quote on
this show right when the government
shows up at your door we're here to help
we're the government you know you are in
deep doooo okay they don't do anything
well he literally reversed it and it was
like did he know he was doing it are
they gaslighting us at this point could
they all be this awful and incompetent I
honestly do not know that actually has
nothing to do with what we are doing on
the program today uh we are going to be
talking about Elon Musk we are going to
be talking about the new president of
Argentina Javier malay we are going to
be talking about the fight against
socialism and wokeism and what the media
does when you fight the Socialists and
the woke hint hint they call you Hitler
and Nazi and that kind of thing uh and
also if you're the bad guys right now
let's say you're the people who were
raping
women and you know shooting Holocaust
Survivors and a whole bunch more let's
say you're like a Hamas type they
pretend you're Jesus that's the upside
down world that we live in but I do
think there is a way out of it as I
often say I think it has a little
something to do with bravery perhaps a
dash of Courage a bit of wisdom and
maybe more than anything else something
that we're all seeming uh to forget
right now which is a pro-human mindset
right we are constantly pushed uh with
this idea of AI and we must listen to
the machine and the algorithms will tell
us what to do and we will own nothing
and be happy uh but maybe there's
something that we have to own that's
inside us and we have to refind it again
or at least reignite it something along
those lines so let's just dive right
back into it the big story of last week
was that Argentina elected a Libertarian
now a Libertarian generally believes
that the government shouldn't do that
much that you should kind of keep what
you earn and you should have property
and we should have basic laws to protect
property in life but that the government
shouldn't be doing all these crazy
social programs and you know that they
should kind of stay out of your way so
that you could live the life that you
want that's generally the libertarian
mindset uh if you listen to the media of
course if you're a Libertarian they will
call you far right so Javier Malay
becomes the president he is now the
president-elect but in effect he is the
president of Argentina and he ran on a
radically anti-socialism anti-communism
anti- collectivism and most importantly
anti-woke movement he wanted to get rid
of all of these crazy
programs that the government in
Argentina had and they've had massive
massive inflation their their money is
in essence worth nothing right now and
he wants to fix that that's why he won
and I think we showed you this clip last
week but I think it'll uh set us up
nicely today uh here he is with Tucker
Carlson right before he became president
talking about the dangers of socialism
Argentina is at the end stage of that
Argentina is now a poor country because
of those
policies what advice would you give to
Americans having lived
it
AR
fre
putting the hair aside which is rather
over the top notice he calmly explains
his ideas as I always say he's not
genuflecting and screaming and doing any
of the ridiculous laring acting that say
in AOC or in Ilan Omar or the rest of
them do he's calmly explaining his ideas
oh we should do things so that the
market is free so that a small
businessman can go and do what he wishes
and we should take away money from
programs like gender in sports and all
of these other things which he's doing
right now he then quotes uh Nobel
prizewinning Economist Milton fredman uh
Milton Freedman who by the way was on
the front page of the New York Times as
one of the leaders of the alt-right
alongside me Ben Shapiro and Jordan
Peterson o and Thomas Soul so you see
the way they treat people who just if
you believe in Freedom somehow that
makes you far right and the implication
there is that then you are racist and
everything else but he's calmly laying
out his ideas and what people who want
to control you fear the most is people
who understand the basic tenets of
Freedom that's how it works uh so here
he is now also explaining the
Ridiculousness of how the media operates
when it comes to people who have kind of
good
ideas
do you think there are more important
things than whether we should turn
5-year-old girls into boys and whether
we should constantly debate whether the
founding of our countries are good or
anything else do you think we should
have serious uh conversations about how
we can do economics right how we should
protect our borders how we should
protect our culture and everything else
that is now what he is importing into
Argentina and I suspect that Argentina
is going to start turning around when
you it's not give exactly I was going to
say give but when you create a culture
that will allow people to flourish and
suddenly they start realizing boy I went
to work today and I received this check
and I have a little bit more of my money
cuz my money didn't go to intersexual
lesbian bad Mitten uh that's nice and
now I can spend a little bit more of
that money do you want to go out to
dinner tonight and then what happens is
you go out to dinner and the guy who
owns the restaurant is like boy there's
more people in my restaurant I think I'm
going to hire another chef and then the
guy who wasn't working suddenly has a
job as a chef and he's like oh my God I
have a job you know what I'm going to do
honey do you want to go on vacation and
then the chef and the wife go on
vacation and the guy who owns the resort
you guys get the Point that's how
capitalism works and that's what's going
to start happening in Argentina now I
have no doubt at the same time the
machine as it exists and the WF and all
of that stuff and the elites and the
globalists they're going to try to
figure out a way to screw over Argentina
there's no doubt about that right they
can't have an experiment of Freedom
actually start working U so we will see
how that fight goes but I think we have
a little hope here and now let's talk
about shaving your genital because uh
manscaped is the how it was the best I
could do with the with I'm trying guys
Merry balls
SMI merry balli from our friends over at
manscaped the holidays are approaching
but what if I told you that celebrations
are starting early this year it turns
out the perfect if does exist and who
else to bring it down your chimney than
the leaders in the waist in below the
waist grooming keep calm and let your
balls jingle this season with manscapes
brand new performance package 5.0 ult ra
featuring the new lawn mower 5.0 watch
all your wishes and mistletoe kisses
come true look nice when you're going
Naughty by going to manscaped.com and
using Code Dave for 20% off plus free
shipping unwrap the gift of smoothness
this season with manscaped manscaped
performance package 5.0 Ultra is the
ultimate bundle for the man who deserves
it all included in this special sack is
the lawnmower 5.0 ult ult ra the weed
whacker 2.0 ear and nose trimmer
manscaped liquid formulas formulations
and two free gifts who's complaining not
this guy the lawn mower 5.0 Ultra body
trimmer and the nose weed whacker 2.0
and hair ear and hair trimmer feature
proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
presence now that you've groom the candy
cane it's time to make sure you don't
smell like a reindeer with the crop
smoother the crop Soo After Shave lotion
and crop preserver anti-chafe ball
deodorant once they touch your sack
you'll never go back the gift of
manscape doesn't stop there two free
gifts that come with this bundle are
manscapes boxers 2.0 premium underwear
and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag once
you're done shaping up it's only right
you put your pants presents in the best
wrapping of all the boxers 2.0 these are
seriously the best boxers I've ever worn
in fact I'm wearing them right now get
20% off in free shipping at code Dave we
use code Dave at manscape.com that's 20%
off with free shipping at manscape.com
use code Dave jingle balls are ready for
the
holidays can we just can we pick this up
[Laughter]
tomorrow all right pull yourself
together D just a second
everybody here's the media labeling
Javier
as a far-right extremist a far-right
Outsider compared to former president
Donald Trump has been elected to
president of Argentina coming from the
farri Javier mle a farri politician the
far right politician farri candidate
farri Outsiders extreme right wing Mele
is just way out there on the extreme
scale Argentina has elected a rightwing
populist right-wing populist right-wing
populist Havier Malay is a populist who
lacks government experience and
displayed erratic behavior and foul
language this is a potentially a
worrisome development he's promised some
radical measures wielding a chainsaw
that symbolizes war on government
spending threatening vital Public
Services he has absolutely no experience
his screeds resonated widely his screeds
resonated widely with Argentine
particularly young men LA's
controversial tirades against the
political class have drawn comparisons
to neighbor Brazil's former president
yire bolsonaro as well is former
president Donald Trump he has been
deemed the Donald Trump of Argentina's
campaign Drew comparisons to Donald
Trump's here in the US Malay who has
been compared to former president Donald
Trump you can guess who congratulated
him by saying make Argentina great again
make Argentina great again maybe these
anti-democracy forces will in the end uh
get overwhelmed but that didn't happen
in Argentina not even close all right
you guys see what they do they do it
over and over again but listen to just
some of the words he's a populist well
populist generally means popular the
people are kind of into you that's
pretty good sometimes I suppose he's
erratic he's worrisome he holds a
chainsaw Jesus he's going to cut vital
Public Services what's hilarious is as
they're talking about the vital public
services that he's cutting we showed you
that video he goes across this board and
literally he's cutting out like gender
Sports gender Equity programs vital
Public Services he has sceds that sounds
like a scary word screeds he's uh young
men love him uhoh there's nothing worse
than young men and who the orange man
Donald Trump and then of course
anti-democracy forces with Joe Scarboro
at the end all the guy is is a
Libertarian you might not be a
Libertarian we could all argue about
what the role of government is and maybe
some people think that there should be a
little more social service or maybe you
should have some level of a pro
progressive tax let's say
I don't really believe in that I think a
flat tax would be fair uh but like you
can have some arguments about that but
instead of making any arguments against
this guy there's no reason to believe
that he's racist there's no because when
they say far right they that's what they
mean it's all they mean is racist now
they're not coming out and saying it
because he hasn't said anything racist
but they have to combine him with Donald
Trump and everything else anyway we
thought we'd show you a couple of the
headlines in the last couple days about
him this is from Jacobin which is a
socialist magazine uh me Argentina's
free market authoritarian president
elect Javier Malay wait free market
authoritarian free market that means
freedom and authoritarian that's the
reverse of Freedom so that does not work
okay uh here's from the guardian uh
Trump and bolsonaro salute Javier Malay
as far right Rejoice around the world
again far right the implication is he's
somehow racist here's the New York times
Argentina elects Javier Malay in Victory
for far right oh God and CNN far right
Outsider Javier Malay wins Argentina's
presidency again if you want to do this
honestly media and I know you don't want
to do it honestly and all you have to do
is not be just abjectly completely
horrible you can be about 80% horrible
and the people will keep swallowing the
nonsense just don't be totally horrible
but I know we're past the point right we
through the UNC County Valley we're on
the other side all you'd have to say is
libertarian free market guy Javier Malay
that would be fine guy who's a little
different than us how about that but
instead he's far right so why am i
showing you this there is a reason
believe it or not it's to demonstrate
how evil and
demented demented and twisted the media
is when it comes to you because it's
never about these people it's it's never
about Donald Trump or Javier Malay or
any of these people it's about you they
will lie and slander and attempt to
destroy you but we never ask ourselves
should we listen to these people why are
we listening to these people we're not
sure anymore they had so much control
over our culture and our information and
our news and our current events that
we've been programmed to listen to them
and I constantly it's one of the things
I talk about on the show and that we
have an internal debate here about all
the time how much should we show you of
the mainstream media right like
debunking their nonsense is good but at
the same point people are tuning out so
maybe we should start ignoring them I
that's a good debate to have and I'm
open to your thoughts on that but I want
to show you uh video of Dana White from
the UFC he's the president of the UFC
we've shown a couple of his Clips uh
over the last couple months uh here he
is just going off on the media and he
Nails it perfect perfectly and again
he's not he's not a politics guy he's
not a politician he's a now running a
fighting organization but he gets it
better than most of the pundits I would
say especially the media if the media
tells you you've got something that
that's going to fail it's definitely
going toing win the media are the
dumbest no nothing do nothing nevering
built nothing on planet
Earth so when they say it isn't going to
work you got a fing home run man you
know what I mean jump in and grind the
the the media these guys think about who
these people are when you really think
about the media who are they where do
they come from why does their opinion
matter what have they ever done what
have they ever created what have they
ever built who's ever depended on a
paycheck from the media nobody they are
a bunch ofing zeros that sit around and
write stories about people who are
actually
doing it's true right like we all know
it's true what does the media actually
create other than chaos look at Elon
Musk we're going to do some stuff about
Elon in the second half of the show but
look at just the last year with Elon
Musk for the 10 years before that Elon
was the hero of the media right he was
sending Rockets to Mars he was building
electric cars he was doing all of this
cool stuff then and everyone loved him
then he started to take some positions
that were a little against the media
mostly related to free speech which is
ultimately why he bought Twitter uh this
is a guy who by any estimation is still
a I would say old school liberal for the
most part and now they hate him and now
they're constantly worried about say
child porn on Twitter which is an
important thing to worry about but they
didn't care about it before he had
Twitter right so everything they do is
to destroy the people who create why do
they go after Jordan Peterson he's
helping people take care of their lives
why do they go after anyone who creates
anything because that's where the clicks
and the views are and if people start
realizing that you don't need the
government to build your business and
you don't need the government to educate
your kids and a whole bunch more then
uhoh then they're going to be out of
business and they're not in the business
of being out of business so why should
we care well we shouldn't intrinsically
care they are of no value I think you
guys are coming around to that right you
get it but their lies their contortions
their confusions
247 that they spread out globally have
everybody flipped on things backwards so
now back to the mainstream media for a
second a little bit from the televised
mental institution known as MSM BC they
have former Senator CLA mccal she's now
a contributor to the mental institution
uh and here she is explaining that uh
Donald Trump is even more dangerous than
H A lot of people have tried to draw
similarities between musolini and Hitler
and the use of the terminology like
Vermin and the the the drive that those
men had towards autocracy and and
dictatorship the difference though I
thinkes Donald Trump even more dangerous
and that is he has no philosophy he
believes in he is not trying to expand
the boundaries of the United States of
America he's not trying to overcome a
neighboring country like Putin is in
Ukraine he is not going for some
grandiose scheme of international
dominance all he wants is to look in the
mirror and see a guy who's President so
for those that believe that they have
issues with President Biden and I'm not
saying that you don't have issues I'm
just saying that you should have a more
issues with the person that literally
wants to ban Muslims in this country he
has always tried he's already tried it
before and he said that he will do it
again oh Lord all right mcal first and
then we'll deal with that girl uh mcal
says that Trump is more dangerous than
Hitler because Hitler wanted to do a
whole bunch of stuff he wanted to make
Germany bigger right you know and uh
expand and kill a lot of people he but
Trump's worse because he doesn't want to
do any of that stuff he just wants to
look in the mirror
the analysis of that that they offer on
that televised mental insation is just
it's it's so extraordinary that that I
mean I really believe it that 20 years
from now when we're past all of this I
don't know if Earth will be here we're
just going to be floating around in pods
going wandering throughout the Galaxy
with God pray that that's where we're at
because otherwise it's going to be much
worse uh we're they're going to be
studying that they're going to be
studying these crazy people uh again I
have a zillion frustrations with with
Trump and I think if he becomes
president again it's just not going to
work and all of the stuff but it's like
yes lady that all he wants he wants to
do everything that Hitler did but not
the stuff that Hitler did but he still
like Hitler and he mostly wants to look
in the mirror and then that other woman
I I who is that other woman does it even
matter just another one of these MSNBC
generic people Trump with the Muslim ban
by the way when Trump did the quote
unquote Muslim ban it didn't include the
top seven most populous Muslim countries
it was specific countries that
terrorists were coming from it was not
uh Muslim related specifically anyway
let's continue because there's more over
on MSNBC Eric swalwell you remember Eric
swell he's the guy who farted while he
was on Chris Matthews show he also slept
with a uh Chinese spy who I think just
died out of nowhere didn't she I'm
pretty sure fangfang died we can Sor
right they're G to fact check me on that
one but he did sleep with a Chinese spy
and that was known by everybody and he's
still in Congress so what are you going
to do uh anyway listen to him uh
pontificate on how much things would be
worse if Donald Trump was President
right now and I also like to step back
uh when I see some of the heat President
Biden is taking and think what would the
alternative be if Donald Trump was
reelected or if Donald Trump was
president at this time can you imagine
what the scenario would be in the Middle
East it would probably be the United
States and Israel in a World War II like
scenario with Iran Hezbollah and Hamas
President Biden has not sent a single
American into the conflict but he is now
pulling American hostages out of the
conflict we're supporting Israel we're
getting Aid uh into the region so far
we've held off other enemies of Israel
and America that's why President Biden
was elected and and that's why I think
he needs to be given you know the room
uh to negotiate you know what is
ultimately a resolution to this
conflict he farted on MSNBC once and I
would say that that is just a sort of
verbal fart what he just said that it's
complete complete nonsense we had peace
under President Trump we had the Abraham
Accords we had the embassy moved to
Jerusalem we had these things under
control we killed solomani so that Iran
suddenly was like oh boy that orange guy
he's kind of nuts if we do some stuff it
might cause a problem who knows what
he's going to do it was the weakness of
this Administration it was releasing $6
billion doll to the Iranians that
instigated we know this for a fact that
instigated everything that Hamas did and
we are it's fairly obvious we are far
closer to a massive big bigger conflict
in the Middle East and worldwide now I
would say under Joe Biden then under
Donald Trump and they still have
American hostages I believe we did get
back one uh American yesterday the
Israelis got one dual citizen of Israel
and America back yesterday but I wanted
to show you something uh because this
video we just put this short up
yesterday and I think and we weren't
even planning on showing this and then I
saw the swallow clip and I was like boy
that that's a perfect segue right there
uh you may remember about six months ago
when we were in Israel and we were in
Jerusalem and we interviewed a couple
people but I interviewed uh well he's
now former ambassador to Israel uh from
America David fredman and uh watch him
talk about Trump's policies in the
Middle East and then uh right that's the
one we're showing right now Trump's
policies in the Middle East and then
let's contrast that with where we're at
now in less than a year the president
recognized Jerusalem is the capital of
Israel and then uh May 14th uh of of uh
2018 exactly 5 years ago this coming May
14th which is also Israel's uh day of
independence we opened up our Embassy
and you know the entire world predicted
that this would create endless Wars and
Untold uh violence and and it really
didn't not at all no there was basically
nothing Bas basically nothing and you
know
[Music]
why that's the other reason why they'll
never be a two-state solution anymore
because it's no longer just about you
know drawing borders and fig ing out you
know the details it's about can we ever
again trust these people to be our
neighbors in ways that they can never do
this
again so you see what we did there with
that short obviously the the last 10
seconds or so there that was from my
interview with David Freedman right in
this room last week so we went from six
months ago talking about all the good
things that were happening in the Middle
East right and they were good things and
and they were about a week away had
October 7th not happened they were about
a week away from signing this peace deal
with Saudi Arabia which now obviously
has been completely shredded but the
point is that where we are at right now
there's no nothing close to a two-state
solution by the way I was I personally
was never for a two-state solution the
two-state the very concept of two-state
solution is completely ridiculous
because it's really a three-state
solution because you'd have Israel
proper you'd have Gaza and the West Bank
which are not connected so you'd just be
creating two two separate terrorist
outposts so and and that would be three
states right you just can't have them
just like bisecting Israel but anyway
the point of all of that is is that
there were uh we had an Administration
that had good policies and now we have
an Administration that has bad policies
policies that everyone is now seeing the
repercussions of and yet uh they are
still calling Trump Hitler and they're
going out of their way to P portray
Hamas and the their terrorist buddies as
the good guys so now I want to show you
this this is from The New York Times
this is just ABS well I'd say it's wild
or it's shocking or something but none
of it is anymore with the New York Times
check out this headline from The New
York Times a disfigured woman whose case
has become well known is among
Palestinians released and that woman you
could see her face she's she's been
burned and badly butchered and the
implication there if you just read the
headline is somehow that the Israelis
did that to her but as uh the Twitter
account points out properly Above This
disfigured woman is a car bomber who
having blown herself up in an attempt to
kill Israelis demanded that Israelis pay
for her plastic surgeries this is how
the New York Times covered her release
so yes she went to a checkpoint blew up
her car mangled her face the Israelis
did give her at least some level of
surgery and they put that up and wait
can you put it back for just a second
because even if you look under the
headline in the New York Times let me
read that part perhaps the most
wellknown name on the list of 39
Palestinian prisoners and detainees
released from an Israeli jail early
Sunday was isra jabber who was accused
of attempted murder by Israel and has
been in jail since 2015 she wasn't
accused of attempted Murder She Tried to
blow up her car and it blew up her face
instead but you guys get it this is
exactly what the new New York Times does
it used to be all the News That's pit to
print now it's all the news that Hamas
makes up in essence uh here's CBS
because it's happening all across you
know the Jews have really lost control
of the mainstream media I thought the
Jews controled the mainstream media
totally lost control uh here's uh CBS
basically celebrating the release of hot
Hamas terrorists and listen to the the
way they frame this just extraordinary
Israel says the miners it's releasing as
part of the truce are
terrorists the Palestinian leaders say
they're just children held for what
other countries would regard as civil
disobedience offenses like attending
protests the plight of prisoners is a
deeply felt issue for Palestinians
according to a recent un report around 1
of the population of 5 million has spent
time in Israeli
jails among those released is norhan
Awad she was 16 years old old when she
was arrested in 2015 for the attempted
stabbing of an Israeli man now 24 she
denies the
charges oh guys she was ACC that's the
video she has a Cleaver and
she's trying to chop someone's head off
you
morons well we're not getting monetized
today guys sorry no lunch um but it
never stops it never stops right by the
way the other people that the children
that Israel released these are people
who were stabbing people shooting people
trying to Ram cars into people right all
of these things Hamas literally right
now still has a six-month-old baby
assuming that the baby is alive like
that that is the difference here anyway
uh let's go to go over to the view we
haven't shown you a clip of the view in
the last week or so uh Sunny host here
she is racist leftist
woker possibly the most unlikable
dishonest person on television Sunny
host uh here she runs cover for Hamas
the exact way that these last two things
that we showed you have done it's
unfortunate that people have um taken
such sides here because this is
something that has been going on for
decades right and um we did show the
reunification of of Jewish families and
I think that was really important
especially little AB Abigail I'm a
mother um I can't imagine having your
your child taken from you and held
hostage by a terrorist organization but
we also there were you know 76
Palestinians including women and
children that were being held in Israel
with no understanding of why they were
being held no Administrative Hearings
and so those um those reunifications are
something that we should also be looking
at and talking she's evil like she is
just evil I can't say what I want to
call her but you know what I want to
call her she is just evil the the trying
to make the moral equivalence between
these people she's also lying that there
was no trials for these people there are
trials for these people they there is
videotape of people stabbing people and
the Litany of things we all know that
and that that she opens it up by saying
it's unfortunate we have to take side
you aoral
vapid here's another clip of Sunny
hustin um I think that you're absolutely
right whoopy
media allowed in Gaza yes there is media
in Gaza I've seen these videos I try to
watch the BBC I try to watch Al jazer I
try to get my
news I try to get my news everywhere
because I and I think everyone should um
and I I I think what's really important
is what happens after this pause because
a ceasefire apparently is a bad word now
so what happens after this humanitarian
pause who is in charge who isn't in
charge are we going to continue seeing
this Devastation in in in Gaza are we
going to continue seeing these three
Palestinian kids going college kids one
who knows my son's friend okay uh when
is that going to stop when are we going
to really meet at the table and
understand that all lives in this
situation are being affected and we must
have a two-state solution no you dimwit
um first oh my God somebody knows her
son somebody was some her son has a
friend I'm sorry for her son for his
mother um you cannot have a two-state
solution in the aftermath of what just
happened and I already explained partly
why geographically it makes no sense the
the cause of the entire Palestinian
movement is only to kill Jews they have
been offered State six times there has
been no Jew in Gaza since 2006 the
Israelis want nothing to do with the
place she's she's she's dumb she's it's
dumb and she's evil and I don't know
what to do with these people I really do
not know what you do with these people
uh and what they are doing is they are
causing anguish and despair for decent
people uh so now here is a decent woman
uh this is an Israeli citizen uh right
outside the Western Wall which of course
people always say it's the holiest site
in Judaism it's actually the second
holiest s side in Judaism because the
holiest s side in Judaism is the Temple
Mount which is right above where she's
standing going to be right out of camera
they don't let Jews pray there Israel
does not allow Jews to pray on its on
its holiest spot in the world in
Jerusalem uh because they don't want to
upset the Muslims and the Jews are
supposed to be the bad guys here anyway
so she's at the Western Wall and uh well
here's someone actually kind of laying
out some truth the hostages have been
underground in Gaza for
days I cry out to every single person
here and every single person on the
planet to make it your mission to free
these Souls 240 Souls they are from 33
different countries their ages range
from 9 months to 85 years old they are
Jews Christians Muslims Hindus and
Buddhists they are human beings and they
need you the world the world leaders the
is isra Israeli leaders they need you to
save their lives in the Torah in the
Bible we are told in The Book of
Leviticus in the book of vayikra in
chapter 19 verse 16 you are forbidden to
stand idly by while your neighbor's life
is in danger I am God each of us one day
is going to die and face our maker we
will each be asked to count for the
Deeds that we did in this world we will
each be asked if we stood idly by what
will you answer them bring them home
now so yeah you do have to pick a side
I'm sorry Sunny host who's laying out
more truth that woman or sunny host over
at the view right you have to pick a
side 33 countries have citizens held in
Gaza right now as she pointed out Jews
Christians Muslims Hindus Buddhists
everyone should care about this because
this is the fight that the West now has
on its hands because it will becoming to
all Western Nations if you think that a
certain set of people because of
whatever their perceived grievances is
allowed to do the most unspeakable
things unspeakable things do you know
that there's video now it's been seen by
several reputable journalists that on
October 7th they literally dismembered a
pregnant woman and took the fetus out of
her that was still alive and they made
her look at it until she bled out and
then and then of course the the fetus
the baby died as well that's what they
did and if you think that that can be
excused if you think that it's tough to
pick a side when it comes to that there
is something seriously wrong with you
and I think we do have to accept that
there is something there is a serious
mind virus in the west and there are
there is something seriously wrong with
a lot of the people that we put on
television and a lot of the people that
we send to colleges and a lot of the
people that we have teach those college
students uh one of the interesting
things now is as more of this video is
coming out um there has just been no
condemnation of Hamas by any of these
quote unquote feminist organizations I
wanted to read to you a tweet from Yash
Ali's who's an actual journalist I don't
have to use quotes around he's he's
talking about a Washington Post article
here he's quoting a Washington Post
article he didn't pick up his pants he
shot shot her while inside her you can
figure out what that means there was
humiliation through rape on the morning
of October 7th a harrowing story about
sexual violence faced by women in Israel
at the hands of Hamas terrorists so more
and more stories are coming out I do
want to show you a bit of good news
because here are 50 of the Israeli
hostages that have been released in four
days and you can see a lot of old women
there you can see a lot of children
there so some of these families are
being reunited and that is a miracle and
this will not stop until every single
one of them have been reunited and Haas
is wait wiped off the face of the planet
which that's the side I'm going to pick
sorry sunny htin I know that's you know
you kind of say they don't want to pick
a side but you have picked the side
actually um anyway here's a video of
women and children who had been held
hostage by Hamas uh reuniting with
family
[Music]
fore
spee
for still can't pick aide Sunny
hustin notice how different the uh the
reaction is the emotion is uh when the
Israelis get their children and wives
and mothers and grandmothers back back
there's there's quiet there is peace
there is it's it's actually unspeakable
right that's just one of many videos
that are now out with this sort of thing
you know what happens on the other side
when the Palestinians get their Martyrs
back they're firing Rockets they're
chanting we want more we want more death
they're joyous they're handing out candy
because they are just waiting for the
next round to do all this and they it is
joyful for them if they kill more people
so if you cannot pick a Sunny host again
you already have picked a side uh
speaking of a guy who picked as side
this one's kind of disappointing for me
personally because I've played a couple
videos of this guy over the past five or
six months in a somewhat positive vein
because I think he's done some nice
things I'm talking about Andrew Tate uh
who's former MMA guy um and he's done
some nice things as it as it pertains to
men kind of getting their lives right
and you know standing up for yourself
and sort of some of the Jordan Peterson
esque stuff so we've played some videos
of him anyway he's really come out uh on
the wrong side of this Hamas Israel
situation and Piers Morgan who I have
some frustrations with because he kind
of kind of takes every side of
everything but but I like to give credit
where credit is due uh he sat down with
Andrew Tate and did just like remember a
couple weeks ago he tried to get uh
Jeremy Corbin former labor leader in the
UK to just say hey is Hamas a terrorist
organization he had asked him 15 times
and Corbin refused to answer watch what
happened with Piers Morgan and uh Andrew
Tate what do you think of of what Hamas
did in October the 7th why are you
starting the story in the middle let me
ask you again it's a simple question do
you believe Hamas are a terror
organization and that's a very
interesting question but I think you're
pedaling Asin nities we just answer the
question can somebody do me a favor
Google asininity are they a terror group
you're pedaling Asin nities because I'll
tell you why Piers let me answer the
question of course you are simple
question going through a border on
October the 7th oh October the 7th
massacring young people at a festival
killing baby oh killing babies that was
true well fine were the babies
vaccinated why are you being flippant
I'm not being flippant the point I am
making I find that funny no but the
point I making is that the media lies
firstly secondly what is your reaction
to what happened in October the 7th sure
I would be an amateur if I could not sit
and pretend I do not understand the
motivations behind either side I still
call the Israeli actions absolutely
abhorent and genocide in terms of what
Hamas did on October the 7th do you
accept that was an act of terrorism it's
an interesting question but because it's
not really it is very straightforward
nothing justifies what happened on
October 7 what are they supposed to do
nothing so what are they supposed to do
that was my question for you is why
can't you which is my position on this
is very straightforward what Hamas did
was an act of Terror and to try and
pretend they're not makes you sound like
Jeremy Corbin I can't give a worse
insult to throw you right so just want
to ask you one more time is what Hamas
did on October 7th an act of terrorism I
think pierce it is pedaling Asin enties
for you you sound like Jeremy Corbin no
let me answer the question 15 times he
refused to answer the question let me
answer the question you're now are they
a terror group or not they're one team's
freedom fighter and they are deemed a
terrorist grp what do you think I think
that if you lock people in an open air
prison and steal their land they're
going to retaliate so they're not a
terror group I think they're going to
retaliate they're not a terror group one
team's terrorist is now about eight are
they a terror group and also another
thing I want to make clear to you only
Jeremy Corbin has done this done what
refused to answer the question I think
that what they are doing
is seemly deemed an act of Terror by the
people that the terror these weasly
words they're not weasly of one more
time is Hamas a terror group who
committed an act of terrorism I think
that when you lock people in an open air
prison you're going to have to
retaliation no because I have to there's
be saying I think it's spineless sure as
a realist sometimes you do not come to
the conclusion of labeling good guys and
bad guys the world is not black and
white bad guys the world is not black
and white the world is actually very
gray anybody who sits and
CLE there's
nothing no clown you are completely
wrong isn't it interesting Sunny host
it's so unfortunate we have to pick a
side right and then what did he say oh
the world is not black and white there
aren't good guys and bad guys this is
what the collapse of sanity and decency
and truth will do people will not know
whether murdering four-year-olds and 85y
olds and raping women in front of their
dying husbands whether that is good or
bad or whether there's any situation
when it is excusable he also of course
calls Gaza an open air prison and says
that they stole their land I might
remind you there has never been a
Palestinian State and before 1967 Gaza
was part of Egypt and before that it was
part of the British Empire and before
that it was part of the Ottoman Empire
and we can go back and back and back and
back and back uh but I know you get all
that but I want to focus on this open
air prison comment for just a second
because there is an Incredible video
that was going viral two this is two or
three days ago uh on Twitter posted by a
pal someone who purports to be a
Palestinian journalist and his tweet in
essence said I wish we could have the
Gaza back from before October 7th now
how long is this video what did we cut
from it all right so we're going to show
you about 30 seconds of Gaza before
October 7th take a look
[Music]
so that's the open air prison that's the
place that was so horrible by the way it
was a three-minute video in in totality
that he posted it started going viral
because people like me started
retweeting it and saying boy that's
quite an open air prison so do you know
what that Palestinian journalist did he
deleted that video we were able to
screen capture it and grab it but that
video is no longer on Twitter because he
realized once it once the truth was
shined on it how ridiculous it was so
that open air prison boy place was so
freaking horrible and not a Jew there
since 2006 right uh it was so freaking
horrible that that is what allows Andrew
Tate to say that yes um murdering
pregnant women is pretty much your only
choice because that's where you had to
live ladies and gentlemen there is evil
and there is good and if you do not pick
a side then by default you are on the
evil side that is really how it works so
now let's get to some of the positive
stuff as we uh get towards the close
here uh we covered it yesterday it was
happening as we were doing the show
yesterday uh Elon Musk went to Israel
and toward uh some of the areas in the
South that were attacked by Hamas I want
to show you a quick clip of that into
the K
itself this is the
house way back you notice several
terrorists that were right over
here uh uh it's a symbol in Boots you
have kids inside mothers and the fathers
run around with it but it's holding
shells specifically of
a that was used here in order to protect
here's a little more video of uh a
mother who had her son uh kidnapped by
Hamas showing the video to uh to
Elon no audio on this one but here she
is showing the actual video and he there
he is he's he's just watching it he also
watched the 47 minute there's a 47
minute compilation video of the
atrocities that that we're we're not
even going to show you here I mean the
stuff literally it is it literally
happened there are many journalists who
have verified it Elon has now seen it of
them cutting open a pregnant woman and
taking the fetus out and letting her
bleed out as they showed the baby to her
I mean things that are if they were in
the movie Saw you would say this one is
too over the top uh here is Elon Musk
now talking about
a better way to uh to go ahead and and
how do you figure out what's going to
happen to Gaza in the future it was uh
certainly been
um a day I would say an
emotionally difficult day uh to see the
places where people were murdered I just
did a talk with the the Prime Minister
and um I think there's I mean obviously
there are three things that need to
happen uh in the Gaza situation I mean
there's no choice but
to kill those who insist on uh murdering
civilians there's no choice um they're
not going to change their mind but and
then the second thing is to change the
the education so that a new generation
of of murderers is not trained to be
murderers and then the and then the
third thing which is also very important
is to try to build
Prosperity you know it's interesting
because he's right of course and this is
what Israel's stated goal is right the
goal is you must kill every Hamas member
period and you're going to have to kill
the ones that are in Qatar too the
billionaires who are running the thing
you're going to have to kill all of them
so it was great to see some moral
Clarity it was great to see someone
picking aside that was number one then
you have to change the education system
by the way he could be talking about
America in this case too right you have
to change it so you don't grow
generation after generation with all of
the wrong ideas and who are breeding
other murderers and all those things and
then the third one which is the most
interesting one to me is that you have
to fix the economic situation now the
irony of that is that that's exactly
what Israel tried to do when they left
right they left them with green houses
they had they left them with uh
infrastructure the UN and all and The
Who and all of these organiz
organizations they put billions
literally billions with a bee worth of
dollars into the Gaza Strip so that they
could build a fully free functioning
Society in the Israeli said we want
nothing to do with you freaks but what
did they do they decided to build a
freaking War Machine and the war machine
is actually quite effective at spreading
Mayhem and medieval barbarity and
everything else uh so Elon is right
about that the problem is this is like a
chicken or the egg situation if you
still have all of these people who want
the murder want the Mayhem want to meet
the 72 virgins and everything else then
what are you going to do uh here's audio
uh Elon uh talking about how Hamas is
actually antihuman and when you have an
anti-human Force there really is only
one thing you can do with that if you
want peace destroy Hamas if you want
security destroy Hamas if you want a
better life for the Palestinians in Gaza
who've been hijacked uh by Hamas destroy
Hamas U all of that is a precursor to
the question that you asked you first
have to get rid of the poisonous regime
uh as you did in Germany as you did in
Japan in World War II these were two
there's no choice there's no choice
that's a prerequisite yes there's no
choice isn't that interesting it's not
that hard to take a stand it's not that
hard to pick aside there's no choice
these people are here to destroy
everything that is good they are here to
kill people and murder people and kidnap
people and do things that we could not
have possibly imagined humans could do
less than two months ago so you do have
to pick a side right uh and it might be
surprising I suppose to some people to
hear Elon on taking such a clear stance
it was very refreshing but it wasn't
surprising it was refreshing to me
because people are so afraid of taking a
stance these days but knowing what I
know about him it wasn't surprising to
me and I would also argue that this is a
guy who has spent most of his adult life
trying to figure out interplanet
interplanetary travel trying to figure
out what the preservation of the good
stuff on Earth will be and then allow
humans to take that out into the cosmos
like this is the good guy in this
situation want to just end with one
other video this is Elon Musk uh a
little while ago talking about Google
co-founder Larry Page uh because uh
Larry Page basically believes well
believed or maybe still believes uh that
you can basically create God through Ai
and the question that Elon poses really
that I think we are all going to have to
think about as as AI becomes more and
more ubiquitous and as I said yesterday
as the as Skynet turns on
are you pro-human or anti-human do you
think computers can create gods and we
should just be little cogs in their
system or do you think that there is
something uniquely important about being
a human well I think I probably know
what you think and I think you
definitely know what I think anyway take
a look I mean the the reason open eye
exists at all is that um Larry Paige and
I used to be close friends and I would
stay at his house in PA walto and I
would talk to him l the night about uh
AI safety and at least my perception was
that Larry was not taking uh AI safety
seriously enough um and um what did he
say about it he really seemed to be um
one want want sort of digital
superintelligence basically digital God
if you will and at one point uh I said
well what about you know we going to
make sure humanity is okay here
um and and and
um uh and then he called me a
speciest did he use did he use that term
yes and there were Witnesses I wasn't
the only one there when he called me a
speciest and so I was like okay that's
it uh I've yes I'm a speciest okay you
got
me what are
you yeah I'm fully asist um busted um so
um that was the last scoll all right so
that's our last video today and I think
you got what I did there that Elon Musk
the people that are fighting for
Humanity who are fighting for the West
who are fighting for Freedom it's not
just that we have to fight Hamas it's
not just that we have to fight all the
indoctrination and the woke and the
stuff that melee is doing down in
Argentina and all of those things but we
have other fights on the way we are
literally going to have to fight the
robots and the people that want to
create digital gods and I get it it's
all a lot but if you are pro human you
should be anti- Hamas you should be
anti-mainstream media you should be well
you should be a spe species right you
should be because we're a species and I
would like to see us continue to
thrive pick the good guys pick the bad
guys pick a side the the time of
choosing is now man the time of choosing
was a while back but it is uh it is
definitely on uh that was quite a
program today I have to say that uh my
manscaped balls never felt better I hope
yours do too uh people of the internet
will be live as always at 1 p.m. uh if
you have not subscribed to us please
join us on Rumble at rumble.com rubben
report we got a postgame show in just a
moment at Ruben report. locals.com oh
and I mentioned that we did do an
interview here in studio uh with David
fredman I I had no intention after
interviewing him six months ago in
Israel that we were going to interview
him again so quickly he happened to come
to Florida for a couple days let me just
show you a quick little promo of that
and the full thing is up across
platforms one of the
important perspectives here is think
about um you know 1,200 um people were
slaughtered on on the uh 7th of
October so to compare that for example
to the Holocaust right that event in
Holocaust terms happened every day for
four years picture October 7th every
single day for four years and that's the
Holocaust and we survived the Holocaust
right so we're going to survive this um
but we're not we're not you know we're
not our parents or our grandparents you
know I mean I'm not as tough as my
grandparents were I mean I didn't grow
up that way I grew up in a very
comfortable life as you probably did and
everybody else we know right well we
both grew up in Long Island about three
three miles away from each other it was
okay we're not cut out we're not cut out
for this we're not cut out to be you
know ripped away from our parents and
stuck in a in a in a hole in the ground
I mean that's not what our G thank God
it's not who we
are um so now you know this this this
episode is uh is causing all of us to
think about what we're made of and how
strong we are and how we're going to
survive we will survive but um it's
causing everybody to really rethink all
their assumptions I've been thinking
about that last line right we will
survive but all of us and it's all of us
again I keep saying this isn't about the
Jews this is about everybody you live in
a western country you live in UK
Spain does not matter right now Ireland
Etc Argentina like all of us have to
think a little bit more clearly because
yes we will survive humans Will Survive
survive but will be will we be better on
the other side will we be handing our
kids something better than we were
handed that is Up For Debate and that is
the challenge for all of us uh I leave
you with a cold clothes we didn't did I
even say Joe Biden's name on today's
show even once I don't who what has Joe
Biden been up to well here you
go uh it's good to see you again we had
dinner last night I told you you sat
next to my wife you were so captivating
I was worried she
likes you more than she likes me now I
don't
[Music]
know